[Music]
alright guys we here to talk about
another topic that has already been
discussed on JK but this is not regular
JK news okay this is social justice
league time do we have a symbol social
leave and we're a mixed community of
multicultural group of friends who the
japanese have to sit over there other
island with no military grounds are the
plans and the asians yeah but today we
wanted to talk about a topic that got
brought up in JK news which is can guys
and girls be friends outside of being
ashamed don't we'll find the video and
leave the link in the description please
where i represented stephen eyes views
and everyone else disagree so what is it
that way was yours wasn't it was guy can
guys in college he converted me to his
view so can guys and girls in
relationships okay guys and girls be
friends like without one person wanted
to [ __ ] the other person so platonic
friendships atonic friendships and I
think what I said was yes if the if they
don't find each other attractive yeah
and if they've been friends for ages
yeah and we're and like if they're in
separate relationships I don't know yeah
like to me when someone's in a
relationship or when I'm in a
relationship either way I that person is
non-sexual like are we talking about are
we talking about let's have lunch and
just gossip all day friends all the
things that you could do with the person
Aereo's and still I feel like Barton Geo
we're still like no no matter what no
matter what they don't have friends so
that's why they can't that could very
well they're only friend in the whole
entire world except for them they
believe that that's not it's impossible
like you should be able to sleep in the
same bed as that person and like if not
then you're in security relationship
wait what okay so they think that is
possible yeah to be friends and not yeah
each other yes okay well I said that
it's disrespectful like if you're in a
relationship
sleeping in the same bed this is
disrespect I think you could be friends
if you're not in a relationship maybe I
don't know but like yeah if you're in a
relationship and then you okay go out to
lunch with someone or like I go hey
Steve I'm gonna go have dinner with an
angel
yeah like it wouldn't be Joe because Joe
and I work together too so that's kind
of different too like if there's a
business aspect to it then whatever but
like yeah some random guy like let's say
it's some guy from my past I'm like I'm
gonna go have dinner with him past like
what kind of past like he used to be
interested Pastore talked about I was
never interested in I thought he was
never interested either you know really
matter
yeah because the the reflection of it is
the weird thing right like so you feel
like it can't be platonic friendships
can't happen I can't be friends with a
single girl for example like as far as
like like I'm gonna go have lunch with
her this afternoon like like and it's
different because like you know like
your ex Jess like I can hang with
because it's work because we're all
friends like it's not like it's like my
friend oh yeah that was another context
that I feel that that that's important
because if I have if we're all friends
and like we all know each other and like
I knew you guys in a relationship and
now you guys are broken up you're still
both my friend and so nothing's weird
because we're all friends yeah him
either like I don't think he's gonna try
to [ __ ] this girl or I don't think that
girl if she made a move on him I don't
think he would capitalize on move has
I'm gonna do with that it's more of a
respect thing that the state that you're
in right now you're already married and
all this stuff and then Steve meet
someone and it just so happens to be a
female and it's not business-related and
they go out and hang out as friends
you're saying that criteria is weird
yeah and because it's like unless we're
all friends like what they're gonna be
out all night giggling with each other
I only make business friends and then I
see if I want to talk about other topics
with you so yours is like the backward
Center so you so for me it's negative
like with people after you got a
business or not beautiful women all the
time like especially in what we do right
but I don't see them as like [ __ ]
partners as soon as they're influencers
entertainers like all that it's bad for
business or fancy students but I will
[ __ ] out of them yeah just waiting just
kid you know it's all about it's really
it's really about different levels right
like I think I'm past that stage I'm
trying to [ __ ] everything in anyone okay
so you know first off it's like what is
my relationship to this person and am I
getting a good read off of how they're
reacting to me right if I was in a
committed relationship I feel that I'm
already busy so that extra time I should
be giving that attention yeah the person
that needs it the most which is my
significant other right but if this was
high school I'd have a different
mentality because you have all the
[ __ ] time in the world right yeah and
there's a difference too like because
Bart brought up in that video like what
if we were all on vacation together and
then you know me and tip splinter off
and you and Joe splinter off and
steveandjessica travel I'm like that's
different we're all on vacation we're
all friends like we're all exploring a
different city it's not like when I meet
some girl while I'm at a bar and then me
and her just [ __ ] hanging out yeah I
mean yeah that's weird but that's not
very I don't really like specifically
like circumstances like specific
circumstances are like weird yeah it's
definitely like a case-by-case thing for
me it's like I do agree with you though
like if I mean I am in a relationship
right now and I for the most part any of
my extra time you know spent on like
relationship building I'm giving that to
her for the most part but I mean like if
she's you know busy usually at work or
something like that and I have a lot of
other friends from like high school and
other friends that I made through
college and stuff like I'll go hang out
cuz I also enjoy having a wide variety
of friends to pick their brains about
different ya know are you hanging out
them as a group is it exactly something
both sometimes yeah
individually with females you girl from
high school and so we go and you don't
want a bugger before
no yeah you swear god yeah definitely
I'll be straight up because I this ok so
then so but the subjects are just hot
because I got a little confused while
you guys are talking is that can you be
friends with someone of the opposite sex
while you're in a relationship with
someone yeah yeah yeah oh I see okay
yeah I mean even when you're both single
I think one person wants to [ __ ] the
other person sometimes I don't know I
feel like that's an American culture
thing because I have a feeling that
Europeans don't see it the same way
about what they don't even think about
it they just much people person to a
relationship later okay and this is only
because I I used to have like a lot of
guy friends and I always thought of them
as friends and then when I got single
day every single one I don't think you
have a good radar when it comes to who's
trying to [ __ ] you and I don't that's
true that's that's valid that's uh I
think if you're very social they know
how to balance that what I've seen
people work their magic and they kind of
know like oh this [ __ ] is trying
to [ __ ] me oh this guy's actually gay or
like this and they know like you know
they have that sixth sense I can't speak
for all dudes but for me I can't be in a
relationship with a girl and not end up
liking her generally speaking you know
anything like I'm not I'll be it's not
every girl but I know me personally I
couldn't just be one-on-one with your
company so much or like it I'm not I
have to [ __ ] the [ __ ] exactly and if it
does get closer I can't be like their
best friend because that best friend is
gonna opt for me is going to turn into
discounting that is it as a factor but
like the extreme of saying like like a
like guys and girls can't be friends
like period like platonically outside of
relationship like I think that's a bit
far of a stretch yeah but listen I'm not
denying that that's a factor for a while
they're pretty [ __ ] cool yeah I know
a lot of cool people who are perfect and
I am attracted to personality right and
so I'm gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
eventually
yeah because I am attracted to that kind
of personality exactly what I was and
that's where he got me because I found
out later that I'm what is called
sapiosexual have you heard of this no
it's where you are only turned on or
physically attracted to somebody after
they stimulate you intellectually oh
yeah I'm kind of in that realm dude yeah
so if I am stimulated intellectually and
then I'm like that's my friend we're
going to dinner like I don't know maybe
like during that it's like a chemical
releases and I'm like that's not cool so
you think it's just too risky to like
play with fire like yeah maybe but I've
ruined my relationships with many of my
girlfriends but not one of sent
girlfriends I mean like friends that
were girls because I always what catch
feelings like if it got deeper and then
you try to unfriend zone yourself yeah I
guess so in a way but I'm not try I was
like before I even yeah before yeah
before I got in the friend zone I would
already map in any time it was like up
no no nothing I just to me it's easier
to get turned off the more time I spend
with someone yeah then to get turned on
and you so it's I can easily have
platonic friendships there are times
when I find a girl super attractive and
I want to talk to her and then just give
me a couple hours and I'm like uh-uh
and so she might still pursue thinking
that like you know there might be some
magic here and then it's just completely
just friendship for me yeah because you
can stop putting them on a pedestal
after a certain amount of you know oh
yeah I see all the flaws now they smell
her breath and you see the [ __ ] arms
on her [ __ ] hair and I'm just kidding
I can see the juiciest titties the most
luscious around as fast but if she
doesn't connect with me on an emotional
level yeah I'm [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
her and I'm never talking very
no no I'm not gonna do that now I know
oh yeah no you're saying zhuzhing if she
has juicy titties and a juicy ass you're
gonna [ __ ] her and I'll talk to her
again
Teddy I see oh Savior yeah but yeah and
then and you're in a relationship or not
a relationship I don't even know there's
a time a shape-shifting time in a man
where like our guy we're like you
actually convinced yourself because you
want to bone so bad cuz it's all [ __ ]
right yeah
that she's awesome she's perfect for you
and all these Dansville I think all guys
have been to that point unless they're
very like evolved mentally and
emotionally and all that but there will
be that shift where that gets tiring and
then you think more long-term like a
woman and guys are [ __ ] we have egos
man we think we could [ __ ] anything
anybody like that kind of [ __ ] we do
but it's too it's it's an ego thing for
guys right so so part of all that too is
like putting yourself in the smartest
situation at all times like I'm a
married man I have no business being at
lunch at dinner with somebody who's
single a single woman like that doesn't
make any sense
that's true cuz some times you just want
to bone them cuz you can well don't I
don't personally but there are
situations even the perception of that
is not necessary because of how men are
wired I don't even need to reflect that
into reality
oh and along your lines too like when I
was single sometimes I just needed to
catch some dick so and and I can't do
that if favor you know yeah not funny
very yes so like I had to ignore like
all the like this no not feeling zopim
em oh I guess but also I was talking
more about like the personality traits
that were a total you know like you just
I don't want to get superpowers you
could ignore that as soon as I see it
it's done for me you get drunk oh I
don't drink alcohol
but then it may catch feelings I can't
do anything about that oh yeah they're
crazy oh I mean I think it's possible I
think it's possible it's doable to be
friends to be friends with benefits not
fringe benefit no I don't know Julia you
had guys that were friend-zoned and they
were [ __ ] totally in love with you
see that's true see do you think that on
your side of the air side she's
torturing max talk to these guys so I
think mine probably is the closest to
the truth right if it can't happen if
both of them are completely and they
have history yeah yeah I'll give you
that and there's maybe the or the if
there's business yeah I agree on a new
new friend thing like especially at our
age - we shouldn't be spending extra
[ __ ] time yeah you don't you spend it
on your [ __ ] significant other and
not individually like maybe in a group
setting maybe like it take back but not
individually that one yours friendship
go to book club yeah it's even harder to
create new guy friends that are deeded
friendships for me now yeah I guess so
you got more time to me but you have
more time
[Music]